it's the end of summer and as crazy as
it might seem now is actually the
perfect time to start planning next
year's magical garden hey they're
saplings welcome back to esoteric
moments I have been spending so much
time this year focused on magical
gardens and gardens in general getting
the land plan for our farm kind of
figure it out and I wanted to share some
of the resources that I found really
compelling for this project the first
book is cultivating sacred space by
Elizabeth Murray this is mostly a
personal kind of memoir book of the
author's garden finding her husband
losing her husband and that whole
process there are different gardens that
the author describes and shows which
might give you some ideas for your own
garden there are some general like
correspondences listed in general it's a
nice book but maybe less design or plant
focus the pictures even are like kind of
small and not as inspiring as some
garden both solid lots of good stuff in
here
but definitely more for someone who's
looking for a book with gardens but kind
of about other things spiritual
gardening by Pegg Streep was really
great it's kind of what I hoped the
other one would be like this one has
massive pictures giant ones on almost
every page and they're beautiful a
really wonderful inspiration book for
the winter month this one talks about
the different ways to approach spiritual
gardening and has about ten or twelve
like example gardens that are really
well described you can tell the author
enjoys gardening knows what she's
talking about and is keen on sharing the
spiritual aspects of gardening with
others one of my favorite example
gardens in here is the Gaia garden which
happens to be in Wisconsin but it's a
good combination of food and plants and
community and spirits it just works
really well and I definitely took
inspiration from that garden on some of
our own plans here magical gardens by
Patricia monoghan was a great read and
clear
written for the pagan druid or witch in
mind this book spends a lot of time
talking about spellcraft ritual how to
utilize your gardens for your pagan
practice if you're like I'm not really a
gardener but I want a magical garden
this might be a good place to start
because it's really coming at this whole
idea from a magical perspective there
are also some garden designs in here
which have like a diagram and a plant
list and then they describe the
intention and use of that garden gives
you some really concrete ideas for your
own magical space I have the 15th
anniversary edition and what I really
wish would have happened is to have some
pictures of how these garden plans had
adapted and grown in real life it would
have been beautiful to like see how the
person living and working and practicing
in that spiritual space how that had
translated over the years and what had
changed but that's the only downside
really is that there wasn't that year
long or actual photographic evidence of
those gardens garden awakening by Mary
Reynolds was probably like this is
almost number one I couldn't decide
really such a great book I found Mary
Reynolds on Pinterest of all places and
had no idea about her work with Wilde
Gardens winning the Chelsea Flower Show
all of that was very foreign to me here
in the US her book is just packed with
land spirits and wildness and real
concrete understanding of how to work
with a landscape to create sacred space
there is hardcore plant lists and
gardening ideas and garden diagrams that
are very in-depth but still this feeling
of like you are working with the land
this is how you communicate and do that
I think it's a great read for anyone who
likes to like walk the land and connect
with the land or just enjoy garden it's
very fascinating read there's also a bit
of permaculture in this book forest
gardening describes kind of the
different ways that that might work not
in depth permaculture by any means but
definitely a nice tidbit and you can't
beat the garden diagrams in this book
she does like an earthworks version and
then this version where you see all the
plant and kind of
above typical garden plan and like plant
lists it's really detailed it would be
hard I think for the average gardener to
recreate this type of plan does give you
like go bold go big do what you want for
your magical and spiritual space finally
number one creating sanctuary by Jessie
bloom this one wins out mostly because I
think it's the most approachable for
many people it talks about permaculture
and design ethos it talks about how to
utilize all those elements in daily
practice as food as medicine it's not
just about design it's not just about
magic or spirit it's also about like
what you do with it afterwards which is
perfect and beautiful a friend of mine
had this on their coffee table a book
club and I just like fell in love with
it on that day when I purchased a copy I
sat on my garden bench and devoured it
in like a whole evening it was just such
a fun read so inspiring and just like
good for the soul kind of reading it has
enough pictures too that you get a real
understanding of like what the author is
doing in their garden and how you might
recreate it in yours but still very
approachable very down-to-earth all
right there you have it my top 5 books
for magical gardening I am so curious
let me know in the comments what book
looks the best to you have you read any
let me know your thoughts
this week's application all goes out to
thank you so much for your comment if
you want to be a sapling shout out
definitely talk to me below or over on
Instagram that's how I can get ahold of
you and learn about your practice and
your gardens and whatever you're up to
thanks for watching and as always may
find peace in the sacred grove
[Music]